the Kappa row type of imply Kyoukai that
can be found inhabited Aruba's in
traditional Japanese mythology in the
folklore capper itself was thought to
mean river child but they did go by
several other names including kama hiki
meanin horse pala and cow atado
meaning River tiger these were just some
of the many names associated of the
Kappa depending on which region of Japan
you find yourself in there are close to
100 names relating to the creature with
Kappa being the most recognized outside
of Japan in Shinto they were referred to
as just one of the many sewage in a name
given to a water deity depictions of the
Kappa do change but they were quite
commonly likened to a child in terms of
size and stature they had scaly
reptilian skin which was known to range
in color anywhere from blue to green to
yellow and they had webbed feet and
hands which served to aid them in their
environment as they were commonly found
in the ponds and rivers of Japan they
were also said to be able to swim like
fish and there are tales of local
fishermen mistaken the Kappa for fish
because of their smell although their
appearance may vary from region to
region there are some features that seem
to be common amongst the Kappa Lee's
been a beak they taught us like shell
and a hollow indentation found on the
top of their head which is commonly
filled of water if this pool of water
ever dried out or was spilt it was
believed that the Kappa would lose its
power and possibly even die been
obsessed with politeness if one was to
bow to a Kappa they will almost be
obliged to bow in return
thus spilling the water held in the
plate on its head making them unable to
leave the bow in position until that
water is refilled this often resulted in
people attempted to trick and outsmart
the Kappa because it was believed that
someone refilled this water the cap
would have to serve them for eternity
the capper are quite an odd bunch of
creatures with a range of varying
behavior they were usually seen as being
troublemaking tricksters who perform
quite harmless pranks such as stealin
food liftin women's Caminos and scaring
the locals but at times their behavior
took quite a malevolent turn with them
drowned in animals kidnapping children
raping women and even eaten human flesh
it became somewhat of a tradition or
superstition for locals with her
cucumbers into the river in order to
appease the Kappa as many claimed
cucumbers to be their favorite meal
sometimes the Kappa was shown to have
vampiric tendency
Lauren people into the water drinking
their blood and eaten their liver and
other vital organs in some accounts the
Kappa gain their powers by taking a
person's [ __ ] or Kodama which is a
mythical ball believes they contain
one's soul which also happens to be
located inside the anus so how exactly
the Kappa would abstract the Shiro
Kodama is something I'll leave up to
your own imagination in regards to the
victimization of animals the Kappa had a
particular taste for drowning horses in
cows and the image or theme of the Kappa
drowned in a horse can be found all
around Japan in these stories it's
believed if the cap was caught in the
act they could be made to apologize the
city of tono became an area known for
its capper attacks especially directed
towards women with several images around
the 18th century showing women being
raped by the Kappa this in turn led to
quite a few accounts of women being
impregnated leading to an offspring that
was said to be so repulsive it caused
physical pain to look upon when
encountering a Kappa normally results in
either being kidnapped raped or drowned
and potentially even having your anus
fondled how exactly does one escape a
Kappa we discussed earlier that bowing
to a Kappa is a way to trick them into
spilling the water located on top of
their head and any method or technique
that would spill this water would offer
an effective escape another weakness
involved the arms of the Kappa which
could easily be pulled from their body
if an arm became detached from their
body the Kappa would have to share its
knowledge or perform a favor in exchange
for its return having some kind of
expertise in wrestling would also come
in quite handy as the kapwa known to
challenge humans to wrestling contests
or tests of skill
despite the Kappa not exactly being seen
as a friendly creature
it's thought if one was befriended it
would provide a number of benefits and
blessings they would sometimes bring
families fish which was regarded as a
mark of good fortune the capital also
regarded as being highly knowledgeable
in the field of medicine of Legends
stating that it was in fact the Kappa
that taught humans had to set broken
bones their knowledge and medicine is
something they would also share with
humans they had befriended they were
even known to help farmers irrigate
their land and receiving the blessing of
a Kappa was a sign of a good harvest to
come despite everything we've learned
about the Kappa and they're quite
malevolent nature in modern-day Japan
they can be seen almost everywhere quite
often joyful and nearly always smiling
being portrayed in quite an inviting
manner the exact influence and origin of
the Kappas
uncertain but some of the names that
they go by it would suggest they may be
partly based on either monkeys or
Turtles perhaps even taking some
inspiration from the now extinct
Japanese river otter regardless of
whether you see the Kappa as a
mischievous trickster or an evil being
they're just one of the many unique and
strange-looking creatures that Japanese
folklore has to offer if you have any
stories or thoughts about the Kappa then
feel free to share them with me in the
comments below and as always I've been
your host mythology in fiction explained